we start tonight though with the person
who represents everything that is wrong
in the Washington swamp that would be
Speaker Pelosi because for weeks her and
her Democratic colleagues they've been
totally completely missing in action
sheltering in multimillion-dollar of
mansions and gated communities in place
as it turns out they were busy behind
closed doors
completing get this a three hundred and
forty seven thousand word wish list
filled with three trillion dollars in
more spending on top of the three
trillion we spent the four trillion and
loan guarantees from the Fed now despite
calling it a Colvard relief bill well
much of the proposal has absolutely zero
to do with the ongoing pandemic in other
words they are treating the coronavirus
like it's Christmas morning just like
they did they kept workers in hospital
workers and businesses small and large
waiting for the first stimulus bill
remember that for a week and a half
delayed it in this one they want twenty
million dollars for arts and humanities
foundations fifty billion dollars for
colleges and universities three point
six billion dollars for the Democrats
mail-in voting scheme twenty five
billion dollars for the post office one
trillion dollar blank check one trillion
dollars to bail out fiscally
irresponsible states and local
governments in other words your
hard-earned tax dollars roughly ten
thousand dollars per US citizen will now
be used to pay off mostly New York
California New Jersey Illinois and all
their waste fraud and abuse this
includes unfunded pensions this includes
their reckless entitlement programs this
includes state governments that love
wasting money after they tax their
states and chase everybody out of their
states look at New York for example
they're they're ninety million dollar
failed light bulb factory or there's
seven hundred and fifty million dollar
disaster solar power plant yeah that
went belly-up also and now Elon Musk
owns it California's $900,000 electric
buses the twelve thousand California
public transit employees making more
than a hundred grand each per year get
this the twenty three million dollar
program in Illinois that encourages
people to ride bicycle
you're gonna bail them out and don't
forget about illegal immigration in
these sanctuary states and cities New
York State they spend an estimated 7.5
billion dollars on illegal immigrants
annually New York City just passed a
hundred million dollar bill to cover the
medical costs of all of its illegal
immigrant residents in the sanctuary
state of California they pay out a
whopping twenty three billion dollars
each year to illegal immigrants is that
what you want your tax dollars spent
bailing out because that's where it will
go
fiscally responsible states they should
demand that their Congress men and women
and their senators reject this it is
literally robbing future generations
thankfully though Flo sees money grab
doesn't have a snowball's chance in hell
listos of now becoming law it is yet
another political stunt even Pelosi
herself she can't even sell her own bad
bill take a look Minority Leader Kevin
McCarthy called it a liberal wish list
of a bunch of items that you wanted to
have passed even before the corona virus
pandemic happened he knows that that's
what he said isn't so but not putting
that aside I I can't be bothered about
what others say what I am concerned what
I'm proud of is what we are doing our
caucus have agreed that everything is
coronavirus centric and also in a timely
way that relates to the virus it's too
deadly to our lives to our livelihood to
our democracy for us to use it for any
other purpose now keep in mind this
massive spending plan calls for a
trillion dollars just for state
governments and just ten billion dollars
for small business grants she has no
shame the Democratic Socialist Party is
no shame never let a serious crisis go
to waste because you'll get things done
you never dreamed you could have happen
that's Rahm Emanuel 101 instead of
seriously working to make this country a
better place opening up the country
safely being productive just like they
have for three plus years nope all they
want to do is become obstacles all they
want to do they're not helping people
recover from the pandemic she's playing
politics exploiting a crisis while she's
been missing in
action pretty much the whole time